[Music]
the belt and rodent itself is xinjinping
putting a name on what have been
happening in central asia for some time
already and then taking that model and
globalizing it the relationship that
china has with central asia is a very
large and complicated one hello and
welcome to chinese whispers with me
cindy yoo every episode i'll be talking
to journalists experts and long-time
china watchers about the latest in
chinese politics society and more
there'll be a smattering of history to
catch you up on the background knowledge
and some context as well how do the
chinese see these issues it's just gone
a year since the chaotic u.s withdrawal
from afghanistan but russia has not
replaced america in the region instead
there's a new great game on central asia
is now part of china's empire or so says
my guest on this episode of chinese
whispers he's rafael pantucci a senior
associate fellow of the think tank rusi
and author of synostan china's
inadvertent empire the book looks at
china's outside influence in central
asia among all the stands and is
collated from a decade of travel in the
region
there were two when they started but
rafael's co-author alexandros peterson
was killed in a taliban attack in kabul
eight years ago
rafaela has gone on to finish the book
by himself hello welcome to chinese
whispers um now in the 20th century
central asia was seen as the ussr's
backyard but china has clearly usurped
russia's influence in the region now and
that's what i want to start by
discussing first can you explain to
listeners the geography of the region
because i don't think i knew this until
i saw a map in your book of where
roughly the stands of central asia lie
in relation to china
so
the countries that we're talking about
the five countries of central asia which
kyrgyzstan kazakhstan tajikistan
turkmenistan uzbekistan are a little
cluster of countries that essentially
sit in between china and russia and are
bracketed by mongolia sort of on one
side that they don't actually share a
border with it and uh the caspian sea on
the other um and then to the other side
you finally got a little corner which
touches on iran and then of course
afghanistan underneath but essentially
they sit in between these two countries
and for a very long time they were
always considered part of the russian
empire in some way shape or form and
most recently um the soviet union and so
these are countries that are really only
30 years young
you know so they're only coming to sort
of a relatively new state of development
and the border that they share with
china was actually only one that was
really defined in 1949 and i think the
other critical thing which is quite
important and really ties china to this
region in particular is the fact that
you've got communities within these
countries you know each country is
called like kazakhstan or uzbekistan
which you know by the name suggests is
the home of the kazakh people or the
uzbek people but in reality there are
uzbeks and kazakhs living in lots of the
other countries as well and so you've in
fact got this sort of large more nomadic
tribes that essentially have had these
borders written around them um which i
think is quite important to think about
because it does emphasize how kind of
interlinked this region is and in fact
how much china is in some ways as much a
part of central asia and in particular
how much xinjiang in some ways is a part
of central asia as some of the five
central asian countries you know just to
give one example there are roughly one
million ethnic kazakhs in china and
kazakhstan has a population of only
around 20 million people so you know
you're talking about quite substantial
numbers that are sort of living outside
each other's borders wow that's amazing
um that nomadic point is really
interesting because i think in chinese
history lessons you kind of historically
know that region is where the nomads
come from you know what in europe we
call the huns um so it's fascinating to
hear about you know the modern
iterations of that so when did modern
china then not not the kind of imperial
times i was just mentioning wouldn't
modern china start to be interested in
that region
so it's um i'd argue there's two moments
i think i would sort of point i mean the
first is clearly when you know modern
china was defined as we know it by the
people's liberation army and you know go
back to 1949 and we sort of see the
borders that were first drawn but i
think what we saw happen for a longest
period of time during the kind of soviet
union
was a borderland that was essentially
very remote and largely ignored to some
degree and pretty fluid in some ways
between china and what was then the
soviet union
i think when you had the soviet union
fall apart it's probably the moment that
we can track the most recent kind of
articulation of china's relations with
these countries because at that point
they became countries and one of the
first acts that we saw from chinese
perspective was the creation of
something called the shanghai five
organization which was an organization
that was initially created to help
delineate borders because these borders
had been so remote and so fluid in many
ways um you know it wasn't clear what
they are and so suddenly when the soviet
union fall apart china finds itself not
only sharing a border with russia which
it had to sort of completely define but
suddenly three entirely new countries
you know tajikistan kyrgyzstan and
kazakhstan and so the initial creation
of this shanghai five entity which was
saying which was pushed by yang zemin
was an entity to try to delineate
borders establish sort of new military
relations and parameters in this uh
space who who else was in the shanghai
five so the shanghai is about for china
um russia uh kazakhstan kyrgyzstan and
tajikistan it was very much about what
the the border that china used to share
with the soviet union it suddenly became
a border in fact that had these four
different countries fascinating and so
now what are its main goals there then
trade and resources would you say that's
bad
so i think the
principal issue that animates chinese
thinking towards central asia
um
is really one about domestic stability
you know in many ways this is true of
every country every country's foreign
policy is defined by its domestic policy
interests right and i think when you're
talking about central asia you're really
talking about xinjiang from china's
perspective and from china's perspective
you know they've seen historically how
xinjiang has had this trouble between a
uyghur minority and the han increasing
majority which has led to violence and
they've seen links to this violence
across the borders because there are
large weaker diasporas in these places
and in the past distance have hidden
there and so we've had a sort of history
of trouble um so there is that kind of
security concern but then i think in the
longer term in some ways you know
we can look at the chinese security
response to xinjiang to try to stabilize
the region and the very heavy security
response but the change come i think
recognizes the long-term stability to
xinjiang is really going to come from
economic prosperity
so from their perspective for this
region to be stable and to not have this
tension between these minority
communities and the majority
they need to have an economically
prosperous region but if you're going to
make xinjiang economically prosperous
you're going to have to find a way of
connecting it to the world because
xinjiang is in many ways as landlocked
and disconnected from the seas and the
you know traditional sea routes which
generate so much of the world's trade
than frankly any of the central asian
countries it's next to so in some ways
to sort of open up xinjiang and make
xinjiang more connected up to the world
and ultimately more prosperous you
really have to sort of open up roots
across land and this is where i think
the key interest one of the key
underlying interest lies with china's
interest in central asia it's really
about trying to improve the kind of
prosperity in this border region around
xinjiang to help improve xinjiang's
prosperity and also xinjiang's stability
um looking beyond that um there are also
this is an area that is rich in natural
resources
oil and gas lots of minerals and these
are all things that you know the chinese
you know economic machine consumes and
is looking for and so of course having
these ripe opportunities right in your
board are of course interesting to
chinese chinese companies so let's talk
about xinjiang first then um
fascinating what you're saying about the
long-term strategy of making the region
prosperous because i think that's often
not discussed um because we were
focusing quite a lot uh on the you know
on the dire persecution of the weaker
people happening in the region um but
then the longer term is the thinking
from beijing make them richer make them
more stable make them more prosperous
and therefore they're not going to be
rebelling against central authority in
the way that they have been so far
yes i think that's the ultimate vision i
mean i think you know the chinese
government recognizes that you know a
very strong security
crack down um it's not necessarily going
to deal with these problems in
perpetuity you know what i mean and so
they recognize that to try to turn that
corner eventually is going to require
something else to have change in the
environment and they think the key
element is you know economic prosperity
and i think they would look around the
country and say look at the rest of the
country you know we had instability in
other places and now we've got wild
prosperity well they all they i mean you
see the same kind of logic going for
hong kong right i mean during the 2019
protest so many uh chinese in the
mainland were saying uh the problem is
the house prices there you know the
young are dissatisfied because of the
house prices and they're channeling it
into political uh disillusionment
seems to me it's quite a marxist
interpretation that economics underlies
everything and also misses the point of
the importance of identity culture
religion
um and but before we get on to that all
of that i just want to first touch on
you know that under discuss part of this
indian policy what is china doing to try
to make xinjiang richer so you've talked
about trade cross-border into central
asia but is there more stuff happening
internally in china as well yes there is
um there's a great deal and you can go
back and i think the interesting recent
turning point in kind of china's
policies towards xinjiang you can
probably trace back to july 2009 when
you had large-scale rioting in urumqi
where
uh reporting was around 200 people were
killed in in clashes between uyga and
han um it's possible more we really
don't know the sort of full details but
that kind of marked an interesting
watershed moment i think in recent
chinese policy towards xinjiang because
after that you saw a real effort by the
central government to rethink the
approach they've been taking until then
because
you know that event took place when uh
then premier hudson tower was in uh
italy at a g7 satoshi what was it at the
time g8 summit in la quina italy you
know as we were being fated on the
international stage you know this is
china's rising moments and so forth um
and he had to leave all of that to go
scuttling back home to try to resolve
this domestic clash right and they're
pretty embarrassing from beijing
specifically after that moment you see a
real turnaround in the policy and a
long-standing leader who'd been in
charge there wang le choi who'd ruled
the province for 15 years or so was uh
well unceremoniously shunted on
and you see a real change and one of the
big changes that you saw was a real
attempt to push more domestic economy
towards xinjiang so you had a lot of
twinning so some of the richer coastal
cities were given responsibility for
prefectures in xinjiang um you know one
example i remember was i think shanghai
was given responsibility for parts of
kashgar and they said you know kadre's
from the region were told you have to go
work in xinjiang you know to help the
local cadres become more efficient and
develop and try to copy shanghai's
success i mean lots of other cities
tianjin beijing others all had
responsibility for different parts so
there was that kind of twinning that
happened
um provinces were told to give some
portion of their gdp to xinjiang to
again help improve the economy as a sort
of aid of the sword
and you saw companies from these various
regions being encouraged to go out there
and i remember meeting in my sort of
travels around central asia you know and
actually in xinjiang as well you know
people from guangzhou whose company had
been told go set up a factory in
xinjiang so they'd go and set up a
factory in xinjiang to try to help you
know the region so there's a lot of kind
of internal economics that happen to try
to do all of this and as well as the
external facing part which right how how
would you evaluate the success of that
strategy because it does seem that uh
often the economic growth that the
region has cut uh has seen
comes at a cost to local culture or
through literally exploiting the uyghur
people's forced labor or at the very
least the weaker people don't get a
share of the growth pipe because as you
mentioned it's han people from other
parts of china coming in is that fair is
that why they're not being co-opted into
this you know very nice sounding mission
i think i think there's a certain
element of that you know there's not
it's not clear how much the people who
should you need to benefit from it are
really benefiting from it um it's very
difficult to sort of objectively
ascertain that but certainly anecdotally
it doesn't seem like it's always sort of
happened but but i think you know the
it's
you know the fundamental question is
what metric do you look at you know and
i think from a chinese government
perspective they would say you've got
stability in xinjiang now and as we just
saw we've seen being visiting the region
he would say well it's now stable we saw
him not talking about terrorism during
his last visit and we saw him talking
about look at how you know
so i think from their perspective
they're looking to say yes we have
delivered that now has it really dealt
with the problem in the longer term and
has it dealt with all the issues and
you've touched briefly on the question
of you know this quite marxist notion of
it all being about the resources you
know and if everyone just has the
resources they'll be happy and not you
know clearly that's not what motivates
people you know people get motivated by
their ideas and sense of self and and so
on so forth and i don't think they've
kind of addressed that in in some ways
so you know i think that it's
questionable about whether this approach
will actually deliver the goal that they
want but this is the chinese government
thinks this is the approach to take and
i think then uh to just sort of on the
wiigara team i think the other point
that we always have to remember with
this is in overall national chinese
terms this is a marginal issue you know
it's always worth remembering that you
know the uyghur people which are i think
about 10 million is the sort of estimate
that people run around with that's out
of a population 1.4 billion in china so
you're talking about a small community
within the country that lives on the
farthest fringes of it most chinese
haven't sort of ever really encountered
this at all so all they've really heard
is what they've maybe seen in the state
media which is frankly a quite negative
story so i mean in overall national
policy terms this isn't necessarily the
priority that some of us externally
would would look at it and so i think
that allows a level of kind of policy
approach that beijing can take which to
us outside we said that's clearly not
going to work but actually it's probably
delivering what they want which is not
generating violence and incidents within
the country of instability which is what
they're kind of trying to avoid um
because i would agree i i don't think
that you know people are always
motivated frankly by my name
they're clearly not there's lots of
other motivations which drive people and
especially if you're living in an
ethnically homogeneous country like
china yeah and you have an identity that
is very different yeah absolutely well
let's talk about identity because in
just one last question on the xinjiang
issue which is that do the central asian
governments and people see what's
happening in xinjiang and are they
concerned about it because there is much
more religious and ethnic solidarity you
one would think but actually i don't
know
you don't really hear the kazakhstan
government really protesting against
what's happening in xinjiang can you
talk a little bit about that so i mean
in my experience of traveling around the
region i must say i found a limited
pool of solidarity towards the the
weaker people suffering in central asia
i don't want to say everyone was
heartless everyone recognized you know
that there was something happening there
but there was a sense where these people
are chinese right
right so they don't think that they're
the idea of east turkestan which some
uyghurs talk about they do but it's but
it's not you know we have it's kind of a
bit of a
it's maybe a simplistic view that we
have of this region we say well they're
all turkic peoples except for the tajiks
so therefore they must all get along you
know
and they must all you know uh be
friendly with turkey and everything else
well that's not always true you know i
remember one of my uh funny encounter in
one of the the central asian countries i
went to the turkish embassy who were
very kind and sort of took time out to
talk to me and i said you know well how
much does this turkey you know
solidarity and thing work and they said
well you know it's interesting we try to
support it and there are lots of you
know turkish schools and so on to
advance around the region um
but they said that one of the biggest
problems they encountered was they would
find turkish businessmen who come out to
the region and just say oh i can talk
you know language to these people and so
they would just try to go do a business
deal and they'd discover actually no the
languages aren't they are close but
they're not identical
you know when you're getting to a
business negotiations you've got to be
precise you've got to be right and so
the embassy would find itself suddenly
getting called by this turkish business
saying could you send me a translator
because you know i'm trying to conclude
a deal do you find because you did so
much field work for this book um over
the course of over a decade um how did
you guys find traveling around given
that language problem because
you you i think you both are fluent
mandarin speakers is that right so i
speak mandarin yeah it's gone a bit
rustier over time but i function in
mandarin and at various moments i
traveled to collee with other friends
and colleagues who spoke a bit of
russian and then we found local fixers
who would kind of help us out whenever
we wanted to okay and there was a
chinese and russian you know how good
was that in getting around
uh well you know we were looking for
chinese people and chinese speakers so
it was you know it was useful to that
regard but it's certainly true that it
wasn't always you know it was useful to
have others helping around with
languages as well um what what i what i
would say in the region is interesting
is you know they um
as time has gone on i have found more
mandarin speakers in the region
and in tajikistan is the most live
example of that when i first went i
struggled we really struggled to find
anyone who really cared there was a few
chinese businessmen there but it was
very limited now there's lots of tajiks
young tajiks who've learned mandarin and
sort of want to know more and the
interesting on the russian side is
actually what we discovered is the more
you get outside the big cities actually
russian is starting to fade away in some
ways and the local languages are taking
over and this is actually something that
the governments are not always that
happy about the one hand they're pleased
their national language is sort of being
advanced but they recognize that you
know if you want to get ahead in the
world speaking russian if you're from
this part of it's not unhelpful
it does open up a world of opportunities
to you that you know maybe just speaking
uzbek does not you know so
it's an interesting kind of balance that
you see there and you get some uh of
that desire to be have a global language
under your belt through people who want
to learn mandarin as well in these
places talk a little bit about the
confucius institutes and their role in
that then
so i was very fortunate i mean you know
one of the things i i have seen doing
this trip this work over and travel
around the region was you know i found
chinese traders and teachers i would
find always very welcoming always very
friendly it was quite curious to have a
sort of white person coming up to them
in the middle of central asia to talk
chinese them you know
are they surprised they were they were
tended to be surprised and sort of
intrigued and curious you know and then
they'd they'd sort of take some time so
let's go and get something to eat which
is really nice but the confucius
institute's always very welcoming
frankly they were always willing to kind
of you know engage and talk to us and it
was an interesting mix of people that we
met there you know sort of there was an
element of some of them were you know
clearly uh people who'd been sent out
there so they were there for you know
two years or whatever it was and chinese
people chinese teachers who hanban had
sent out to go and you know
educate the masses kind of thing um
and you know they were kind of there
punching a clock and they were sort of
complaining about the locals and so on
so forth and then you had some who
really embraced it you know there was
one particular teacher who i saw over a
number of years who kind of stayed on
and clearly was very happy there and he
had the local students really liked him
as well and he was you know very much a
teacher you know he saw himself in that
light and
it was interesting because whenever you
know we're always trying to understand
what were the institutes doing you know
was it how much was
you know that there's a lot of concerns
sometimes about narratives that they're
pushing and yeah and culture that
they're trying to sort of warp and they
were always very clear that you know
we're here to teach these people
mandarin okay you know and they would
avoid they would say oh no we don't do
any cultural things and actually they
did tend to do cultural things as well
and but it was it was it was it seemed
like quite a transactional frankly
relationship and it was all about trying
to get these students to learn mandarin
and then they they in turn you mentioned
at one point but they in turn were
learning mandarin often not because of
some kind of romantic ideal about the
chinese language but because of the real
benefits it could give them in in their
careers i mean one of the big things you
noticed was you know when you'd ask the
kids you know
anyway should i share john wayne you
know they would say oh
babashua you know it was usually their
parents have directly told them i need
you to learn mandarin because you know i
need you to be able to go talk to the
guy in guangzhou who we want to do
business with and i want you yeah so
there was it was a very kind of
transactional relationship we found very
few who you know were like i studied
this because i want to read you know in
the original language or something you
know there was there was one very
charming young woman we met in um in
uzbekistan who was a very fluent
mandarin speaker and you know was
correcting me all the time and you know
my mandarin works but it's i recognized
something she's like your mind is awful
you know she kept correcting me but she
um her goal was to be a presenter on
cctv
she thought this would be a really cool
and wonderful thing to do have you
caught up with her has she made it i
haven't seen her on tv yet to be honest
with you but i must say i don't watch a
ccv or cgt in a huge amount so it's
possible
but she was very ambitious and very keen
to do it and you know but she was a
rarity i must say it was so confucius
institutes are quite a live topic at the
moment in the uk um in particular
because rishi sinak as we record he is
still in the race for a tour leader um
has said that he'll ban them liz trust
has pretty much signaled similar things
legislators in the british government
have said that they want to basically
put more restrictions on them such that
alternatives perhaps from taiwan will
come um
concerns are basically that they spy on
their students that they promote some
kind of ccp narrative
did you see signs of i don't know i
guess political infiltration in the in
the target central asian gov
countries that these confectious
institutes operated in when you were
traveling around
i mean i did see things that i wondered
a bit about but not within the confucius
synthesis to be honest with you uh
within the confuciencies themselves i
found
you know what looked like what they were
trying to be which was didactic
institutions you know and i must say the
most interesting thing to me was to look
at the different countries
and to see you know because we talk
about central asia we've been talking
about it as one homogeneous regions it's
not of course these are five very
different countries in many ways but if
you were to put them in brackets let's
say you could look at kyrgyzstan and
tajikistan and say these are very aid
dependent countries and you could look
at kazakhstan say a very wealthy country
you know uzbekistan which is you know a
big trading nation and there's a large
population and turkmenistan which is
a very difficult country in many ways um
but one where it's quite difficult to
get a grip on exactly where where where
sort of wealth or property sits it's a
rich country but there's lots of
dissonances within
but so within that bracket the confucius
institutes fit
in the sense that in the a-dependent
ones
you know these are countries that they
want help from everybody so if someone's
going to come and offer them a free
course you know to learn a language
which will help them advance in some way
great they need it you know what i mean
there just isn't other stuff there so
there's like a benefit and so you know
you could see that there it's really a
question of do they want to go to the
confucius institute or do they want to
go whatever american institute is based
or you know the british council if it's
there and frankly they'd like all of
them to be around because they can see
an opportunity there for all of them so
the institutions end up feeding that
need and the need is a very kind of
pragmatic one i think when you look at a
place like kazakhstan or uzbekistan
which has got some very good
universities with long histories of you
know teaching languages and other things
it's a very different kind of
relationship and so the confucius
institute in some ways become poor
siblings to the local universities where
actually the local universities where
the real mandarin teaching is happening
and as you see some hanbon teachers
being sent there but it's a very
pragmatic kind of relationship and i
think some of the political influence
and interference questions that we worry
about here and control on on the on the
discourses in the in the university
campus
it's a very different conversation sure
in the central asian countries about
what discourses have permitted in those
sorts of environments anyway yeah so
because it's a very different class
are they almost all one party systems
anyway politically speaking um
no i mean kyrgyzstan has elections um
you know the elections unfortunately
usually result in violence but uh in a
lot of the other countries you have you
know governments that have a pretty you
know smooth transition from one to
another um but you know it's
it's not a
democratic polity in the way that we
might look at it here where you know
some open election which you know has
multiple countries i just wondered if
there was like a strong man affinity
between china and its dealings with some
of these uh countries yes i think there
is certainly some of that there is
certainly some of that there is
certainly some which might also be
relevant for what we were talking about
just now with a weaker uh treatment
um
i think
there's a an element of that i think
there it's more a question of we
uh you know they where they do worry
about xinjiang uh they do worry about it
more in terms of when they're co-ethnics
getting involved of course so the kazakh
government has lobbied the chinese
government for
better treatment kazakhs who are caught
up in the systems in china and there
seems to be some evidence that it might
have worked actually i think the uh
kyrgyz have tried to do the same thing
to targets as well and they've had some
protests in their countries that are
expressing solidarity for that but what
you don't see is a wholesale sense of
condemnation of china and what it's
doing um you know
in the same way in part because yes
they're you know they're all countries
that kind of have a
one-party structure and you know can
kind of want to support each other and
don't want to undermine each other and
you know don't throw stones in glass
houses right so you know there's an
element of that that plays into it as
well
and a sense that you know frankly the
chinese don't criticize what we do
within our yeah
so we're not going to criticize what
they're going to do
sure i want to also talk about trade um
raphael if you can give an overview of
the economic interests um that china has
with these five countries maybe just in
terms of sectors because there's energy
isn't there but there's also resources
and minerals so maybe just give a brief
overview of what what the main picture
looks like
so i mean the trading picture is uh
quite substantial and quite important
for all of these countries has grown a
lot over time
energy is a key component of it uh of
course you know china has uh investments
in hydrocarbons fields in kazakhstan in
um in turkmenistan to a great degree um
in respects on tajikistan a bit um
there's just not that much there so you
know there is there energy is a big
component of it but i think the key
thing i would say is energy in all sorts
of ways
so for example china's big consumer of
uranium from kazakhstan um china's also
quite involved in the renewables sector
in these countries both in terms of
helping them refurbish old
infrastructure that they have but also
build new ones um so you know and there
are even suppliers of petrol you know
there's chinese companies doing you know
supplying gas at the pumps in these
countries so the energy relationship is
much more complicated than just saying
they're buying you know their companies
that they're digging up oil and i think
that's the key point that i always try
to find was that it was you know we have
a tendency to think about the
relationship with china being quite
binary quite simple in sort of one track
but actually it's just incredibly wide
ranging so we talk about trade if you go
to any market in central asia it's full
of chinese goods you know and that's
chinese goods of every sort you can
imagine and actually increasingly
interesting you can see if you go to
like taobao or you know or some of these
chinese platforms you can see that
actually central asian companies are
setting up
uh you know platforms on these to try to
sell their goods into the chinese market
so and that's a lot of agriculture
frankly products and you know quite a
simple things like that that you know
they produce so it's a very kind of
wide-ranging relationship you know that
goes into all sorts of directions and
it's really a case of you've got these
countries that have natural resources
that goes beyond hydrocarbons there's
minerals there's copper there's zinc
iron all sorts of other things that the
kind of chinese market wants um
as well as products you know by products
i mean everything from you know white
goods to pens to well frankly all of us
get all about goods from china these
days right so you know that's true of
course in a country that's neighboring
it but but then you know the the other
side of this is is of course trade uh in
terms i'm sorry investment investment in
terms of you know infrastructure
construction there's a lot of that
that's happening as well um and you know
it's it's always interesting to observe
that this is the place where the belt
and road initiative was first announced
i'm sorry christened
and i think that's very much because the
belton road in itself is
basically xi jinping putting a name on
what had been happening in central asia
for some time already and then taking
that model and globalizing it so i think
this is why i think the relationship
that china has with central asia is a
very large wide-ranging uh and
complicated economic one that goes far
beyond the simple narrative which you
often hear which is these are countries
which are natural resources china what's
his natural resources that's component
of it yeah but it's actually a much more
wide-ranging economic relationship well
i thought one interesting part um in
your one of the many interesting parts
in your book um was about sometimes this
difference in the chinese relationship
with uh these countries compared to the
russian relationship before for example
you give
this example of oil refineries
and how russian companies like gasprom
would split up regions within the
countries whereas china was doing it in
a slightly different way could you
explain that and what you identified as
the difference between those
relationships were
so i think the
if i put it in really simple terms
i've always thought the relationship
that you had between
russia and the region and china in the
region was in some ways russia doesn't
really see this as an independent region
it kind of sees an extension of itself
you know and so it treats it in a very
paternalistic way and you could see it's
companies operating in a similar
environment they say well you know these
are just these you know poor central
asians of course we're going to do
business there and we'll tell them what
to do and we'll kind of control this in
the way that we want to control it
whereas the chinese approach was far
more transactional it was we're coming
to you country x you know in this case
kyrgyzstan you know what is the need
here you know we'll offer you a project
we'll offer you loans to do that we'll
send our companies to deliver the
project you know you'll agree to these
terms or sign an agreement and then
we'll do it and it's just very
transactional very focused on that
specific need and interest
and the wider part of it doesn't really
matter you know the wider part of it
well that's someone else's problem to
worry about whereas russia takes a much
more kind of as i say paternalistic view
of this region uh and that extends in
all sorts of economic ways as well we
can see russian companies treat it as
their kind of you know natural backyard
if you will and even if you look at the
sort of constructs that have been
created in some ways the economic
constructs to link this region up
you know to russia and to uh to china
specifically you know russia had so back
when the soviet union was falling apart
the then leader of kazakhstan nazarbayev
uh
suggested the idea of creating what he
called a eurasian economic union
and it was an attempt to basically try
to keep the economic you know sinews
that kept the soviet union together
going because central asian countries
recognized that they were suddenly
getting pushed out into the cold and
they really didn't know how to manage
their own national economy this way and
they were very tight to russia it was
very important that way and so he
suggested this idea but it never went
anywhere because moscow had other
preoccupations he wasn't really
interested in having to bail out these
countries now
in i think it was around 2005 you see
the russians start to reawaken this
conversation and you see them pushing
this idea forwards and now they very
much realized it and essentially the
creation of the eurasian economic union
which in central asia encompasses
kazakhstan and kyrgyzstan
essentially gives moscow control over
these countries tariffs external facing
tariffs and it has a very strong kind of
relationship
customs exactly exactly what it is it's
customs union but and it's very
favorable in some ways and a lot of
people i've spoken to these countries
have said you know look when we signed
up to join this eurasian economic union
we thought there was going to be kind of
a benefit for our companies as well but
they they said i actually really turned
out it was the russian companies that
really benefited from this right you
know so it's very much a relationship
stacked in that way now the chinese
approach you know i'm not gonna say it
was much more magnanimous in some ways
but it was much more transactional so if
you look at the visions that china's
offered in economic terms you know
there's the shanghai corporation
organization that evolves from the
shanghai five that we briefly talked
about before where china has long talked
about creating free chariot area within
that it's never actually taken off um
because not all the partners wanted but
that was really about trying to improve
trade between all this area right and
doubtless chinese companies have been
able to benefit but the idea would have
been others would have as well and if we
look at the belt and road initiative
it's really about offering projects to
these places and sort of doing those
transactions
and that as i say the russian approach
does tend to be a little bit different
that's really interesting what do the
what do these countries then think about
the fact that they now have a new um i
don't know big boss in the area that is
not the ussr russia anymore but it's
china how do they feel about that
i guess we can say you know what is the
political um
interest in china and also does public
opinion differ is there more sinophobia
in public opinion yes there is in short
there is a great deal of i mean you know
one of the things we always found
slightly consistently was a very basic
kind of racism you know towards chinese
in the region you know they're very
you know horrible yellow peril kind of
narratives you know there is that you
would find that quite frequently at a
public level and
it's interesting that the conspiracy
theories that you you list you know
people talking to you in hush tones
about you know how these chinese roads
are built so that they can hold the
weight of a chinese tank right you know
it's quite funny stuff but you can
definitely see how that takes root and
it's actually quite terrifying yeah yeah
no there is there is a real there is a
real edge there you know and it's it's
it's quite dark in some ways and you
know you do have instances of clashes
between communities that happen and
quite a lot um
quite a lot that's an exaggeration but
they do happen it's not infrequent and
you know um it's it is a very kind of
you know basic race but what's
interesting is sometimes you know this
problem actually escalates to the point
where it causes problems at a national
level because the governments of course
have a very different view of china yes
because for them this is a big economic
opportunity you know i mean the central
asian countries recognize that you know
they're sitting next to the world's
second largest economy now and you know
this is clearly the big growth story of
our time and that's what they want to
connect with so they can see the
opportunities there and they want to
advance it and you find often that you
know it gets
uh you have public protests happen to
the point where they have to sort of
hide projects or walk back from deals
that were being struck because it was
causing so much tensions well you also
describe how some chinese companies
basically hide their presence uh in
cities you know it's very hard to see
any there's anything chinese about this
business site at all is that yeah no i
mean there are some cities in kazakhstan
i'm seeing the sort of oil regions you
know where you you'd go there and we
know cnpc is a very big player but you
just couldn't find evidence of them you
know and you sort of asked the locals
where the cnpc guys and they know we
don't know what you're talking about you
know we tried to find a chinese
restaurant and you know they sent us to
a korean one instead
you know there's no sense of you know
that they're really hidden away and you
know we did finally find some of the
chinese engineers and they said oh we
live you know outside the city at an old
soviet sanatorium where we're all kept
and
but i mean you know i know also that
when these companies have people going
in to
to kazakhstan in particular but also in
some of the other countries they're
briefed about you know what they should
do and they're told you know always
traveling in groups you know make sure
if a local officer shows up you know
here's what you should do you know well
yeah because it's not just the locals
that have a preconceived image of what
the chinese are like because what we're
seeing when the chinese go to places
like africa is that they've have a
stereotype of the locals there as well
being you know uneducated or
fundamentally lazy is that same for
central asia as well very very strong
sentiment to that i mean you had a lot
of case i think a lot of instances where
you know these people are just lazy you
know they don't work as hard
and and and this plays in an interesting
way in the kind of state state
relationships because in a lot of cases
you know one of the issues we found
sometimes is you know people say chinese
companies when they come they always
bring their own workers
you know and this you know it's
something that you know is negative
because you're depriving the locals of
jobs and what you'd sometimes find with
a company and say well you know
we want to deliver this project in six
months and the government would say we
want that project in six months you know
because there's some local election
cycle they want to hit you know the
leader wants to show oh i brought you
this you know wonderful new road or
whatever you know and and they would say
well look if you want us to do that
we've got to bring in chinese workers
you know and so the government would say
yeah well you know the local rules say
you must hire this many locals and fine
we can do that but it's gonna take nine
months you know and so what tends to
happen is the government say yeah let's
just
make it happen okay and so they would
sort of sweep it through and
but yeah the those kind of narratives
are kind of indolent locals who are not
up to the standard of chinese workers
and actually it plays the other way
which is that you know the the locals
will look at the chinese workers say
these people work like dogs and they're
prisoners you know what i mean they're
actual you know former convicts of china
who've been sent into the region to do
these horrible jobs because they
couldn't conceive why these people would
work 24 7 for you know a long period of
time and live in pretty grotty
conditions and seemingly be okay with
that and you know the truth is there are
some pretty diligent chinese workers who
are willing to tolerate these because of
the paycheck at the end which they will
happily send home so you know it's a you
know but the interpretation of that in a
local context is very interesting yeah
and and rafa we're quickly running out
of time when we haven't even talked
about afghanistan at all well they for
listeners who do want to know more about
afghanistan i have done another episode
about that uh which we can link in the
description
but just one question which is kind of
related to afghanistan the subtitle of
your book is an inadvertent empire what
do you mean by that so the notion
inadvertent empire is that you've got
this part of the world where china is
becoming the most consequential player
on the ground
but
we find very little evidence of beijing
having a plan about what to do you know
and very little evidence of any thinking
about well what then does it mean if you
become the most consequential player on
the ground in the sense that you know
these countries will look to you for
problems these are countries
unfortunately that have problems within
them if we just look at the past year
you've had major instability in
kazakhstan uzbekistan which was a shock
to everyone by the way in those two
countries
in tajikistan you've still got a lot of
valentine's day and you've got border
clash in kyrgyzstan and tajikistan um
and you've had the taliban take over in
afghanistan so this is a region that has
is volatile should we say and
increasingly you've got there as the big
player
a power that has very little interest in
trying to resolve any of these issues
that will look at this in a very kind of
transactional way was there more
political leadership from the ussr and
um from the us as well when when they
take leadership in parts of the world is
that the kind of leadership of a great
power the responsibilities of a great
power that china hasn't quite stepped up
into yes i think that's a very accurate
way of putting it frankly the old the
other powers that have sort of had this
dominant role in the region have taken a
very different view to what what they're
doing there i mean the united states you
know experiment 20-year experiment in
afghanistan was you know a
state-building one right
did it work well
uh you know but that was the effort
there you know try to reconstruct this
country in this way you can still see
the us has strong relationships with a
lot of the other neighboring countries a
lot of conflicts with some of them as
well if you think about iran um but you
know that that's kind of the vision that
they always had where china just does
not have this approach at all it's much
more again transactional very focused on
what is the deal we're trying to do here
and now but the point is that those
deals are
huge and they have game-changing impact
within those countries you know in
afghanistan for all of the american
effort and investment that you saw over
20 years there the biggest investment
projects
into the country
were chinese now projects contracts were
signed
not maybe as much happened as should
have been expected frankly and in the
project in messianic the copper mine
there you know signed in 2007 nothing's
happened since
um you know so so there's a question but
it was chinese companies that were doing
those big investments and actually the
afghan government at the time was very
eager to encourage more of that and
actually the new taliban government is
as well you know because they all see
that china is kind of the big economic
player in their backyard and the one
they want to connect with so
it's an interesting dynamic that you've
got this region which has
increasingly come under kind of chinese
thrall and where china is such a
consequential player
but the approach that china's going to
take and the vision that china has is
just so different to frankly the
approaches that you saw before and it's
not going to try to resolve any of these
problems it's just going to let them
play out and see what happens and deal
with whoever comes out on top and very
finally then raph we hear a lot about
this indo-pacific tilt but central asia
is not in the indo-pacific and there's a
lot of detention on china in africa
china in south america but nobody ever
talks about china and central asia
except for at uni right now um so do you
think that the west is um overlooking
this part uh the political geopolitical
tensions and ramifications here look i
think that this is one of the huge
lacuna frankly in western strategic
thinking it was one of my endless
frustrations that we have this sort of
constant obsession with the maritime
china and what it's doing there um and
there is a zero discussion of the fact
that china is becoming the most
consequential player on the eurasian
heartland now what does that actually
mean and what does it matter it's a good
question now if we go back and look at
history and we think about you know the
great geographer alfred mckinder he
identified this region as you know the
geopolitical pivot to the world and he
who controlled this would control the
eurasian island and controlling the
eurasian island means you control the
world right um that's in very sort of
grand eloquent terms but i think more
seriously you know if we think about
recent times some pretty major problems
have emanated from this region and
instability in this region has a direct
contiguous link to
europe for a start you know so there is
a there is a kind of direct connection
there that i just see no real serious
strategic thinking about it's this
fixation with the maritime relationships
and you know what we see happening there
which i think misses the fact that there
is this giant change happening in the
eurasian heartland where there's no sort
of engagement now having said that
there's no engagement i think that there
is some thinking about happening in
washington um but it's definitely not
the priority you know there are
definitely many other priorities and i
can kind of understand why but i think
in european thinking it's a real missing
piece you know where i think a lot of
european
strategists are so obsessed with sort of
focusing on following the sort of
american push to the seas that they're
kind of missing the fact that the
contiguous territory that they have with
china
is you know this space
from china is shrinking this area is
becoming increasing chinese influence
then that is you know something they're
not even even trying to deal with people
often compare and they say a lot a
question i've been asked a lot over the
years as well you know look at what the
chinese do in africa you know how those
relationships play actually that's just
what's going to happen in central asia
and i think that misses the point you
know because to go back right to where
we started you know this for china is
about domestic stability and security in
xinjiang so it's a very different kind
of relationship that they're going to
sort of continue to manage going
forwards and the kind of interest that
they're going to focus on there and what
they're going to do and how they're
going to advance it is
linked to their direct domestic security
not you know in africa quite frankly if
so project goes wrong
shut up shop move on to the next one
let's just not do that again you know i
mean you can't do that in central asia
because you're the neighbor and so it's
you're just going back home and you're
creating problems which are going to
come and blow right back at you so it's
a very very very different relationship
and i think it's one that really there
should be a lot more thinking about the
consequences of it um you know look
we've just been fighting a war in
afghanistan for 20 years
afghanistan's the region that we're
talking about here so you know problems
from this region do have a habit of
reaching out and hitting us so having a
better sense of how we're how we're
managing equities and how the future and
how stability is going to play out there
is i think quite important
well if you're a policy maker and you're
listening to this podcast i've got a
book to plug you
actually ralph you can plug your own
book um what's the full name the book is
called cynostan china's inadvertent
empire well there we go buy a copy buy
your family coffee send one to your
friends everyone christmas must be
coming soon you know exactly rafaelo
pantucci thank you so much for doing
chinese whispers
[Music]
[Music]
you